yeah so similar to last week's speaker
the last time I was in this room I was
actually defending my PhD dissertation
and then I was talking of course about
mapping in a rabid obtuse and today I'll
be talking about mapping in tomato he
full disclosure I'm not actually a plant
breeder I'm a bioinformatician but a lot
of the projects that I work on have
direct applications to useful
agricultural traits so hopefully that
counts and then also Joyce mentioned I
have a little bit of an heirloom tomato
obsession so here's my rainbow of
tomatoes from my garden two years ago
last summer wasn't so great because it's
a bit wet and various disease problems
occurred but two years ago it was great
so these are my babies
so I'll be talking about tomato and also
closely related species today so in this
phylogeny you can see what I'm
considering members of the tomato clade
so there are 13 species in the tomato
clade you can see that one of them is
actually missing here but I'll be
focusing on these today and there's also
solanum lycopersicum IDs which you can
see at the bottom of the tree so that
that is also in other species we'll be
talking about today which is an
out-group so the nice thing about these
is that they can actually be crossed
with varying levels of difficulty so the
ones towards the bottom of the tree tend
to have selfing at that ability and also
unilateral and compatibility which can
make it a bit more difficult to cross
those two cultivated tomato ones towards
the top of the trees towards the top of
the tree are tend to be self compatible
these are mainly found in western South
America so Peru and Ecuador as you can
see a map here see if I can get this
thing to work
maybe this there we go so here and
there's also two species that are found
in the Galapagos Islands this is a
little bit blurry go up again see and
she's mania which are found solely in
the Galapagos Islands they look kind of
similar the different wild species of
tomato you can see some of the diversity
here so have work ideas tends to have a
lot of trichomes so it looks kind of
fuzzy you can see in the middle here
there are some seedlings that we were
growing in our greenhouse at the bottom
you can see however Kai Dee's the
reference tomato is something like a
first-come Hines so that's growing in
the middle of this tray here I don't
think this is really working and then at
the top we have pimping Ella folium so
pimping Ella folium is pretty closely
related to the cultivated tomato you can
see there's variation in fruit color and
size so the wild species tend to have
smaller fruits and they also tend to
ripen too
so they never actually changed to Red's
like your typical garden tomato there's
also the two species from the Galapagos
Islands cheese mania and go up again see
that are orange fruited so that's kind
of unique and you see here a number of
fruit that we got from Roger at T GRC so
he sent those and from there fruits that
they grow there so that was that was
really nice for one of our experiments
and you can see the diversity in color
here's some of our wild species growing
in the greenhouse so you can see that
they're indeterminate so they get quite
large they have this sprawling phenotype
as opposed to some of your more common
Gulf cultivated tomatoes which are
determinate and and don't get nearly as
tall so as I said you can cross the wild
species with cultivated tomato and this
turns out to be really useful because
cultivated tomato has undergone three
bottlenecks so there was the original
bottleneck that happened during
domestication and then the second
bottleneck happens when they moved to
when they were transported to Europe and
then a third bottleneck occurred and
they were transported back to the US for
breeding there so it's estimated
something like five percent of the
diversity so there's a huge loss of
diversity in the cultivated tomato and
so what's nice is you can take the web
species which which have a lot more
diversity and interesting traits and
then you can cross these two to the
cultivated tomato and you might think so
here's some more of my Tomatoes you
might think that they're you know
looking at that fruit shape that there's
actually quite a diversity of phenotypes
there but it's actually controlled by a
few low sigh so few genes need to sort
of this diversity of phenotypes that you
see here so the allowed species have
been used and breeding for a number of
things so this has been happening for
the last several decades so they can be
used in breeding for disease resistance
so you can see one of our collaborators
on a project is interested in tomato
yellow leaf virus so he has a cultivar
that is resistant to that so you can see
in the bottom picture on this line is
called gh 13 the plants in the back are
nice and healthy
the resistance and the ones in the
foreground are not resistant to curl and
today also be talking about bacterial
spec so that's another trait that wild
species have been used
to increase resistance to that problem
the weld species can also be used in
quality and nutrition and then some
other things like leaf morphology and
flowering time so today I'll be talking
about some different projects that we've
had and the common theme and all of
these is using bioinformatics approaches
to map genes of interest and tomatoes
and their wild relatives so the first
thing I'll talk about is defining
introgression boundaries and this
started originally is something else and
when I first came to Lucas's lab as a
postdoc we were handed the sequence from
go up against easily annum go up against
e so this was an interesting species
because like I said it came from the
Galapagos Island so it evolved in
relative isolation until recently except
for a couple other species that were
finds in the island it's very closely
related to like a purse to comb and most
of the work done at that time and even
now it's it's a bit unclear where it
falls on the tree so the go up against
he actually falls here with cheese mania
eyepin Piniella folium and lycopersicum
so it's a little unclear how these
species are related whenever you do
phylogeny x' so we wanted to do some
work to try to clarify that using the
genome sequence and also since we knew
that Heinz which is our reference genome
has pimping Ella folium and its
parentage we also wanted to figure out
where and the reference genome Hines we
could find introgression x' from pimping
ella folium so in order to do that we
selected an old heirloom line yellow
pair so you can see another one of my
garden pictures there so this is an old
heirloom line that existed prior to
modern breeding programs so it should be
free of introgression so this was our
control basically
to do this we devise a pipeline that's
that's adapted from wait a tall paper
that came out in 2009 so we had five
different species that we looked at so
we had the reference signs genome that
we used to map all of our resequencing
data on - we had the go up again see
pimping Ella folium data that came from
the tomato genome project so that was
publicly available
we had our yellow peri sequencing data
and then of course potato sequence is
available at the time so we mapped all
these to Heinz the resequencing data -
Heinz and then we created genomes from
these so we substituted in the snips in
any place we had a gap we mask those out
we also then masked with repeat masker
so we could get rid of any repetitive
regions that we couldn't be really sure
where they mapped to Heinz then we did
whole genome alignments with these five
species we ran helps you tried to
delimit where the phylogenetic
breakpoints were occurring along along
the alignments then each one of these
partitions we ran this Derby is on to
determine a tree for that partition and
then all these trees were mapped back on
to the Hines genomes that we were able
to see where a change in topology
occurred along the chromosome in
conjunction with that we also plotted
the density of snips across the Hines
genome so this was resequencing data so
we used a standard snip calling pipeline
map the data called snips and then we
put these into bins of ten kilobases and
then we plotted the density of snips
along the chromosome so here you can see
at the at the top of the diagram or at
the picture we have on yellow pear and
then the the second species is go up
again see and the third is folium so if
you look at yellow pear where where that
red circle oval is you see there's sort
of this little peak and the snip density
and then if you come down to the last
plot you see that there's a reduction in
so that's a putative introgression
and
we took that location and then also used
our data from the whole genome plots we
found that there was a change in
topology so you would expect Heinz and
yellow pair to be clustered together in
the tree since they're actually both
from lycopersicum so that's sort of the
expected topology if you move on to
topology too you see that it's flipped
so now Heinz is actually closer to pin
Piniella folium so this is indicative of
an inch regression and then when you go
outside that little blip you see it goes
back to the original topology so by
using this method we were able to find
four regions in the Heinz reference
genome where there introgression x'
have occurred so one is on chromosome
four we're not really sure what that is
it might just have been happenstance we
don't know of any known resistance genes
that are in that region and chromosome 9
we have verticillium genes so we were
able to find introgression from pin
panella folia that in Piniella folium
that introduced those genes into Heinz
and then we have the I gene for Fusarium
wilt resistance on chromosome 11 so we
were able to delimit the introgression
x' for each of these genes and Heinz
which now is really useful because Heinz
is our reference for other things that
we're going to do so we want to be able
to rule out these introgression x' that
are occurring in our in our reference
genome so that we we don't think that
they're something of interest in the
population that were that we're actually
looking at okay so now I'll talk a bit
about napping a single gene I'm using a
mapping mapping population with the
close relative the Heinz
so this was some some work done by Sarah
Hines and Greg Martin's lab and it was
really fortuitous because we had just
sequenced yellow pair and Sarah shows up
in my office and says you just found
this interesting phenotype with yellow
pair and I heard you have the sequence
so it got off to a really good start and
so the phenotype is that yellow pair
actually has reduced resistance to
bacterial infection which you can see
here on the leaf on the right you can
see much more symptoms of
then on the on the leaves on the left so
this is great because we had the
sequence so we can go ahead and try to
find some candidate genes for this
phenotype and just to remind you again
this tree is really blurry but the two
arrows are pointing to like a Persico
and pin Vennela folium so these are two
very closely related species and these
are the two species that were used in
the cross so le 1589 is pimping ella
folium and that is the same accession
that was used in the tomato genome
project so we had C punts for that we
had the yellow pair from our previous
work and so Sarah cross these two to
develop the mapping population and then
she took all the susceptible she took a
batch of susceptible plants which we use
for the next step of the analysis this
was our overview of the pipeline that we
use to identify the gene so the first
thing was to take those susceptible
plants so Sarah put them in two batches
of 13 plants and three pools so those
were then sequenced on one lane of
aluminum and those were mapped onto the
yellow pear genome so from her previous
work and they go up against e project we
already had a yellow pear genome so we
mapped these reads from from her samples
onto yellow pear and then we called
snips so whenever we call snips the
snips that we find should be coming from
Pimpin ella folium so they should be
pimpin ella folium and then we plotted
these the frequency of these across the
chromosome and then once we had a region
of interest then we went in to see what
actual genes were there so this is from
her paper and that's what the plotting
of the frequency look like from pimping
ella folium as we go across the
chromosomes and if you look at try to
use this thing again there we go
chromosome four which is great
where my red thought was briefly you'll
see that there is a reduced frequency of
pimping ella pimpin out for you
Oh Liam snip in the dense it's frequency
of the snips and it drops off towards
the beginning of the chromosome so that
was our region of interest to try to
find the gene that's responsible for
this phenotype so the really great thing
about that was that as I said we had the
yellow pair we had the panzanella folium
we went into that region and we look for
any snips that were causing a change in
the and the coding sequence and so what
we found is that there was one gene and
yellow pair that had some deletions that
were causing a shift frame shift in the
coding sequence and that was only
happening in yellow pair it wasn't
happening in pin Fenella folium or Hinds
or the other accession that we looked at
so this is a pretty good indication that
that that was our G so we developed some
markers and Sarah went on to do some
fine mapping to confirm and it does turn
out that that was the actual gene
conferring the phenotype and then she
went on to do a number of very elegant
experiments in the lab to elucidate what
what this gene is actually doing if you
want to know more about that I'd highly
recommend reading for paper alright so
the next thing another project is moving
onto qtls and here we're mapping to an
intermediate relative so not not as
close to cultivated Tomatoes with an L
folium and this was some where we're
coming out of Greg's lab so a former
postdoc in his lab C long bao notice
that in this particular accession of
Habra Tydeus we have resistance to
Pseudomonas so you can see and the leaf
on the left looks nice and clean and
then you can see the really susceptible
one on the right and then there was also
an intermediate phenotype here which you
can see in the in the middle so again
keep in mind this is a little bit more
distant species that we're using in this
study so the reason that's important to
keep in mind is that some of these
issues with detecting recombination and
then also using Hines as a reference
genome gets a little bit more tricky
so this is from his paper an overview of
how we did the analysis so he mapped PT
OS which is essentially cultivated
tomato to Hobart IDs developed an f1 and
then f2 population f2 s were bar coded
individually and then sequenced and then
we align these two Hinds we called snips
one of the problems we ran into is that
the read depth was a bit on the low side
so we had to create a tool that would
actually create bins of genotypes as you
go across the chromosome so since the
snip density was so low as oftentimes
difficult to accurately call
heterozygous sites so by taking an
average across the bin we were able to
determine what the overall consensus
genotype should be for a region so that
was how we handled the low low coverage
data in this case so then we took those
average genotype calls and went on to
perform standard linkage analysis with
our QTL so in doing that we found some
we found a region on chromosome 2 in a
region on chromosome 8 the region on
chromosome 8 ended up being basically
the whole chromosome and there was very
little recombination there so he decided
to move forward with chromosome 2 since
it was a little bit more more
approachable so we went on similar to
Sarah's project to design some markers
so we used the fabric ID sequence that
we had from the resequencing because
there isn't an abra Katie's genome like
there is for Hines and so we develop
some markers based on his sequence and
then he was able to find that to about a
1 mega base region on chromosome 2 and
there are a number of genes candidate
genes there that he did some further
work on to look at expression it was a
little bit tricky though so this this
project was obviously more tricky than
the fo3 project for a couple of reasons
first of all we're looking at a QTL so
we don't have this single strong effect
locus
and also as I mentioned it's a more
distant cross so we had this problem
with reduced recombination and some of
the chromosomes and then also there
isn't a have work IDs referenced you
know so whenever you're doing something
like this if you don't have a reference
genome for both of the parents you don't
really know what is in that in that
segment there so it's possible that
there could be genes that are in there
that aren't in hinds all of these gene
models were predicting from the hinds
annotation so we know that oftentimes
resistance genes they can be rapidly
evolving and they can change by copy
number so what would be of interest is
to have a hyper kinase genome to see if
those same genes are actually found in
hauberk IDs in that region so this was a
good good experience for us to give us
sort of the rationale for having a
reference genome for other projects so
sort of alluding to another project here
so knowing now we know that having a
reference genome for the more divergent
tomato species is really helpful we
moved on to a project with like a person
so this is a very divergent species so
it's actually an out-group to the tomato
clade and you can still cross it with
cultivated tomato but it's a bit more
difficult and it's interesting so this
this was also another nice accident so
there was a postdoc there still as a
postdoc in Jim Jim and Tony's lab that
was doing some work on the like a purse
acquittees inch regression lines out and
and I feel that they're you currently
using this is a couple years ago and it
was really good conditions for spec that
year so re the postdoc was interested in
in looking at some fruit quality related
things in the in theone introgression
lines but since the conditions respect
were really good he was able to see that
there was some some plants that were
actually resistant to the spec so now
it's super interesting because it has
two really cool things going on now so
we wrote a proposal to the tryout triad
foundation at that we have it BTI and
rewarded a bit of money to to pursue
this project so you can see here than
the introgression lines where they've
found various low side that are involved
either in fruit quality so carotenoid
biosynthesis or pathogen resistance so
with the triad what we were able to do
is make the genome for like a purse of
quality so we were able to sequence it
using our funds which was really great
because it's really helped a lot of our
downstream work so what we did was we
sequenced the genome at about ATX
coverage using PacBio sequence and then
we corrected those reads so if you're
not familiar with pat bio and it's a
very very high error rate so the first
thing you need to do with it is map all
of the map the reads to the longest
roughly 20% of the reads and then
correct those reads so that's what you
use for assembly we tried two different
assembly tools so Falcon is known as the
diploid assembler and then we also tried
Kenya which is a modified version of
Solaris onblur that's used for PacBio
so we ran two different assemblies
actually many different assemblies using
two different tools and we found based
on n 50 values average length you know
the resulting assembly size that the
Kent can new assembly was the better one
so we move forward at that and we did
polishing using both the PAC bio reads
and then also we had Illumina reads so
we we mapped all those onto our genome
and tried to remove as much of the error
as possible because PacBio often leave
in Dells so those obviously you don't
want to have and then we took that
polished assembly and we use that we
sent that off to dovetail to do hi-c and
also there Chicago libraries
and that was magical because whenever we
got that back it is chromosome length
assembly so we basically have our
assembly and 12 pseudo molecules once we
got that back then we just did a little
bit more work to fill in gaps because
the hi-c will create gaps in the genome
which are just ends so you can take your
PacBio reads and again map them and
sometimes you can span those gaps and
fill in the missing sequence so this is
what our assemblies are looking like so
far compared to the published pignoli I
and the publish lycopersicum genomes so
you can see that the hi-c did a great
job we didn't have really any good
genetic Maps to use for like personally
so the hi-c was able to pull in all of
these scaffolds and get our genome
assembly up the pseudo molecule level
the longest sequence and like a persica
Lidia's it's 133 mega bases so that's
basically a whole chromosome which is
really great hunting size is huge which
is again good because we want to predict
gene models so if you don't have really
long stretches that continuous sequence
you're not and the total length is is
comparable to what we expect the genome
size to be for like a person quiz so
we're pretty happy with our results for
this this genome these are this is sort
of a standard analysis that's done with
with genome assemblies and also
annotations to give you an idea of how
complete your your genome assembly is so
these are genes
Kuzco or a set of genes that should be
universally conserved and they should be
present in single copy and the plant
lineage so you you look for these in
your genome to see how many of them you
can find and you can see so a 29 one
that's like a person ladies and you can
see that we have very very few missing
we actually have fewer missing than if
you run the same analysis on tomato 2.5
so it's not really statistically
significant but it's it's pretty cool
and then these three other assemblies in
blue or other
PacBio assembly as we did with coffee so
I just have those there as a basis of
comparison and overall things are
looking really good we do have a bit of
a higher duplication level and like a
person ease of the boosts go set but I
find that if I remove so whenever you do
the hi-c you get your pseudo molecules
and then you get some other sort of
context that weren't pulled in so if I
remove those that number drops and I
think a lot of that stuff that didn't
get pulled in is actually another
haplotype that was assembled of course
there's also probably chloroplasts in
there as well but that would be what
would be causing this this duplication
because like a person Queenie's it's
very heterozygous so we would expect
that there would be some cases where the
two haplotypes didn't get merged
together and they assembly all right so
of course what people really care about
with genome assemblies is finding the
genes so our next step was to run
software called maker so maker works by
first you repeat master genome because
it's you leave the repeats in there it
confuses the gene prediction software so
you repeat repeat mask and then you
train some ab initio gene predictors so
we used a Gustus and snap so you train
those with a training set so that you
have a model for what the genes should
look like for the particular species
that you're annotating and you put all
this into maker you also give it EST is
RNA seek data all kinds of expression
data basically feed that into maker and
then it'll give you a bunch of predicted
gene models that are never 100% correct
but they're a good starting point of
where coding regions should be so and we
did that we got about almost 38,000 gene
models though this is comparable to what
you see in Familia and like a person
come they should be pretty similar and
then we took these and then we tried to
do functional prediction with those
you know what are they likely to encode
and we use this using blast sequence
similarity and then also InterPro scan
which looks for domains in the protein
and this is a nifty little tool that
we're really trying to encourage people
to use so as I said with the annotation
you never have things 100% accurate so
one way of helping with that is to set
up these instances of web Apollo and so
users can come in and actually edit
their gene of interest so that's that's
what this is here so basically what you
have of your gene model up at the top
that's the predicted gene model from
maker and then you have tracks below
that show all of your RNA seek data we
had Isis secure I used to see a sequence
that comes from PacBio sequence and
what's nice about it is it should in
those cases give you a full-length
transcript so those are really good for
annotation we have RNA seed from
different tissues and all you need is an
account so we have this set up for
cultivated tomato - if any of you are
working on that and are interested in
particular genes you can contact us and
we can set you up with an account you
can go in and actually change gene
models and correct them and all this
goes into a database and then whenever
we release a next version of the
annotation all of your changes will be
incorporated
and I just thought I'd throw this out
there in case any of you are interested
in like a Persico eighties we will be
making this publicly available and the
next week or two so this will be
pre-publication it'll be free for anyone
to use as long as you agree to and it'll
be on sole genomics database so you can
let me know if you're interested in that
alright so now that we have this genome
we want to move forward with with the
projects to look at these genes that are
involved in disease resistance and fruit
quality so how do we do that
so we developed a pipeline for making
for predicting for creating markers to
map traits and in these crosses so since
like a person CODIS and like a Persico
more so divergent oftentimes it's
difficult to get enough recombination if
you have if you generate enough to
actually map genes very well so one of
the things that was done was to cross
like a purse of COI T's to Pei which is
a little bit closer so we can actually
get more recombination and and find that
gene so because of this I did we made
the pipeline so that it would give us
markers that are for use in crosses
between like a purse acquittees and
pinellia and crosses between like a
personal use and Heinz so we mapped like
a purse acquiesce to the published
finially i genome and Heinz genome and
then we used mummer for that and then we
took those results and we identified any
region where we had an end all that was
greater than 30 base pairs but less than
200 and those parameters can be tweaked
but that's what we used and then we use
primer 3 just to design primers on
either side of that endo that we could
use to distinguish differences in the
aptitude population excuses markers and
to confirm that these would actually
work in PCR then we took them and we
blasted them back to the respective
genomes because
since the genomes are quite different
sometimes the primers wouldn't match a
hundred percent or sometimes they would
map too far apart or do something
unexpected so it's important to do that
last step and so in doing that for like
a purse acquittees and ping-mei we have
about thousand markers and for like a
purse acquittees and like a purse to
comb we've got about 600 markers and the
reason there's less for like a purse
acquittees and like a purse economy
because again they're more divergent so
less things aligned then also and we
would blast the primers back since we
were predicting them on one genome
oftentimes those primers wouldn't match
100% and the other genome so there are
some tweaks we can make to the pipeline
to brought a lot more markers if we
needed to all right so the last mapping
approach that this is a work in progress
as well and again a collaboration with
with Greg Martin's lab is to see how we
can use G was and tomato to look look at
novel disease phenotypes so for this
there is a lot of data that's publicly
available for various tomato lines and
also wild species I'm Fenella folium so
we've taken advantage of this so there's
a paper where they see plants 360 lines
there's most of those were like a purse
accom there's another dataset of 100
line some of those include wild species
and then we also have snip chip data and
some other things that were just put
into the SRA NCBI mm-hmm so we took all
of this data and we generated this big
tree from all of it and this this isn't
that tree but it kind of gives you the
idea this is a subset of those
accessions that which is a little bit
easier for presentation purposes but it
gives you some idea of how things sort
of fall out so it's how you would expect
like a person combs cluster together
then you have your landraces
here by the star and heirloom lines the
blue is sarasu for meso sarasu for me is
generally believed to be admixture
between some vanilla folium and like
Persico then the green at the top we
have pimping Ella folium and then the
yellow is some more divergent wild
species so this was useful because now
we can select from these clusters
representatives to do for to use for
screening so we want to get a broad
picture of the diversity that's present
in tomato based on this work with the
resequencing data so Sara Hein
too was a postdoc in Greg's lab and
Samantha have that work to select
samples from this tree and then to
procure seed for them so I think right
now in Sandy's office they're running
like a whole germ plasm storage center
there's a lot of seed from this and then
Robin and Holly are also in Greg's lab
are involved in screening so they're
screening for a novel phenotypes
pathogen phenotypes of Pseudomonas
responses to Pseudomonas and what's
really nice is that since we have all
the sequence data and now we're getting
these phenotypes a tie-in with it we can
try to use G was to get at the low side
they were causing these interesting
responses so this is some work done by
Adrian Powell and he's been using so the
first thing that he tried to do was we
know F ls3 is involved in pathogen
response we have sequence from a number
of individuals or non responders and lot
more who were responders so taking all
the sequence data and the phenotypes
that we already have he did some work to
see if we could actually detect the
known G and you can tell from the
Manhattan plot he was able to do this
there is a bit of noise but you see this
nice strong peak on chromosome 4 and if
you
you zoom into where that is occurring
that actually is at the Ethel s three
locus so right now
Adrian's working on fine-tuning this and
then he'll be interested in applying
this to the new phenotypes that are
coming out of the screen and the last
thing I wanted to talk about briefly
it's a little bit of advertising for one
of our group number so he wrote this
program called snip Benner and this is
useful for the creation of BIM maps so
if you're if you have GPS data or RNA
seek data and you generate a lot of
snips oftentimes that that can be a bit
too much information the bin maps are a
way of sort of reducing the complexity
of that data so the first thing it does
is he so in this case it's been tested
with rails so it takes each line and it
looks for the crossover points in each
line and then based on on an algorithm
it takes those crossover points and
constructs have been mapped from that
data and then and also the other thing
about it there are some other tools that
do some similar things but this one if
you have a VCF file it basically will
take VCF files from any set color and
this is just a little overview of
basically how it works so at the top we
have the reel so first it does a step
that I'm not showing here where it uses
some hidden markov models to identify
the genotype so do you know type Colin
can be messy so it does some work to
sort of smooth those out and determine
the recombination breakpoints which you
can see at the top and then it uses an
algorithm to take those recombination
Maps and collapse them into a bin map
which can then be used in QTL mapping
so this has actually been used in a
paper that we hope will be coming out
soon by ET ganda and jim japanese lab so
he used snipping her too in his analysis
of some fruit quality traits and a
pimping Ella folium tomato real
population so that will be coming out
soon in the meantime if you really want
to play with a tool it is publicly
available on github so you can go there
and try it out so far we've only used it
on Rails but I believe that each eye has
been testing it out on an f2 population
actually that's two population from that
have work IDs project that I talked
about so if you're interested in using
it on f2 we can touch base with him and
see see how it's working ok so nearing
the end here so as I said I work as a
bioinformatician and I'm very very just
absolutely thrilled that I get to work
with all these wonderful people in
molecular labs that are willing to share
their data with us and let us let us
mine their data for exciting things so
as you probably noticed a lot of this
work was done in conjunction with Greg
Martin's lab specifically I'd like to
thank Zi long Val who worked on these
projects their hind who was the lead on
the fo three projects on Samantha who's
doing the work with the mapping of the
like a person Queenie's genes and then
also Robin Holly who are doing this big
screen and working with Adria on the G
was in the juvenile lab specifically I'd
like to thank Ari who's done a lot of
the RNA sequencing for like persik
wienies genome which allowed us to do
the gene model prediction e ty who
worked with David on the stiffener
project and you men who is awesome or
any extraction give us really high
quality RNA sequence for their RNA for
our Isis leak sequencing for the
annotation also the Muller lab who is
always extremely helpful and obviously I
spend a lot of time there and the glove
again see work was done when I was a
postdoc in his lab
our collab our collaborator Buuren years
ago and specifically Alessandra and his
lab who has helped with the like Persico
nice genome project
Roger T GRC who always is sending a seed
and things that we need to get get our
work done and of course the BC BC group
which is joints mentioned is is newly
formed so David who wrote the step in
our software and Adrian who is doing G
was analysis amongst many many other
things
and so here's David's in the left corner
there and Adrian's on the right and then
there's some photobombing in the middle
there and this is a really exciting day
for us because this is when we got our
first PC PC server and that empty slot
that we're peering into is where our new
one terabyte memory server is currently
residing it's working very very hard on
assembling a milkweed genome for George
and ER right now so exciting day and of
course money it's good that you know
people give us money to do things so
huge thanks the BTI has supported a
number of the things that the BC BC
group is doing and a stuff that
occasionally does hand out money and the
Triad foundation for like a purse
acquittees
project and one last thing
one last advertisement for any of the
grad students and postdocs or really
anyone if you are interested or want to
know more about bioinformatics problem
with your project you run this
bioinformatics hour at BTI
on Wednesdays 1:00 to 2:00 and Thursday
is 10:00 to 11:00 in the Resource Center
where the fish tank is but I hear it's
going away so if you want to stop by
during those times it's free you can
come and talk to us and maybe we can
help you and also we'll be starting the
bioinformatics course on March 13th
so and these are the topics that we'll
be covering so if those are things that
are useful to you that you'd like to
know more about just send me an email
and I can let you know the schedule and
and sign you up so I think that's it
thank you
your attention
[Applause]
yeah so he wants something very diverse
process so for the G ones that I
mentioned that particular that was just
looking within like a personal yeah I
think Adrian who is sitting behind you
and can you can correct me if I'm wrong
but um I think we're trying to stick to
like a person comb because whenever you
add pimping Ella folium then there's
structure issues and all these other
things so yeah other questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu